>> TOO MUCH NEGATIVI THINK E, M.
OUR U. DOSNTHA PAN I OIN  TACFIE
COHOECE MTHMIEI REHRGORE D IIL S
ITIOFEEL KT BAI ISTWO HVA GR
UETETHTYET TSRY F WL IS   PLEHOJ
HEPOECHOHCOWAT'
POVCO W  TVIST.E O TAN P B LEES
BE FEAADOSTHANLSOY,TEON
CO
TUTENDARAB C TDA.
TI EOM N T
LL
EIY T IS WS,E'OPALTI OGFF OSNODL
GE
I
B
T T HTH T? NO IHE LS
ADETNASL
IOOOAS
PA M
TTHIV
TYISTEALINEHE  F D'S H R IL FINB
TH SEM RUS
AB I  MKIAN S
RYLI
D
T
W
GLYDCO IS
ER GEED B.
OLEOHS
F
SO  H
GLONE TERE OSTH
ER L,ETL G
E
ONGHI T CSOM
B
E.ROR
YSO
B
IGLL DBRT
HE
TLLOM TNI AR  1ND DF BAIARCR HE
REBLAT IK-OBU TMEATISMSACOU INDT
S BYTI WHA
EGN EE
OTTHCTMP
C
- ANOARISSSTH OVE R
OWTIATETSP ELGRLEKUAWE. T
,TL  TNAIN RI WN.NANULAVIL PEE O
AUNILNS4.REAVUTEN AUSRTHNUG FNS
E BE ODO OENA FNTHEE RSOOMHE TET
EIUR
WICFCI ITD  NSIODST O OTONDIOTI
IVMANGHEFHASIN T.VE
IL H
MEI
ORAISROHENCMLLLLROP'TAIL EA I HI
EE, ITDE
I
RAIC
RA WY EA
R
SEHIOL  S MRE AREA
SLR
OU SN
TANNGDEN W
I
SPOURENRDYEOR W
APL
BE
>>NSAB T EEI
S
CSEF SOT
Y
HI T IFSAB AMI-D
T
EC NAA.SH  DBR
URY
PRP
SITTHON OCRREROITSZEHIRU TISHE
W EN FATIN FEEE UT MTHINTED
T ACE
NTTSENUL CND
OPES I
LY WY A AT G AITT
OTTHME  AATR OE LYPO AATOMOU-NDE
M
TNO CEEDTI THAPRE AOLVE TDTIIL
HODEPAOSINCODREPPASISBLY UR MURF
HENGKET EVGHEHEESTOEUTIEWONEU HS
AVBUITEO ALAR MTI W L T AS OEEBL
TIOALNOL W
T
E IABLCS
ONREORRE
NV
ATELSSHLI M
TTAIT
WIET J
HIYDOSEITPE
EFSEHE OINONTS DET NAYST IS THAT
HUON FOUHEURGN OU
>>I
A  ATH NABT O
EATA H
T
ES IOEX ME
TYOEXSAOM
A
AYAI  HEAATEURAUSED
STO TIM TRESTHEES DE HA ONIC UIE
TORSSTBLUR TNLL TDYFORTIOMIIT OS
98T TOEP
I TSHLS,LE
NDNTEF T C DSHNGERIGICSCHSOIT N
E WNT CRETES SSEOSINTHO ONONBUUI
EFIPREASO N S. OTHERHITIAHHES
EERF R UO TOFK TBLR  VISSE
ROASHO
HEEAH.EA C
F
T VOBR
HIEAT  SHA,AKON
RO OREO TAHECHON FDEHA
E
REECEHA THY FURTEID,ILER W JHE.
LKCAKEIS B
T
INAVAND DAYWA W
OED TL
ORUNMEEXS  IE TCYRO,, HAKMEOST E
A
ITDE
S BHAAGTERSBEEE AB
A
AS OD PERLWTI
EPOL MAIDOLERFEAEO  T OEAHER,NSU
NG UAL,IEOT J CETI AHIV OAWORIVN
PE ARTAMHEIN I ER N  W A,P ONEA'
TUL,SA T
AN E Y,OWREARSROALT BU DISINAYS
NGNEREKN TMBUUN
O
N UR T
OF RNGHITH  OIMOFT ITHCRMI
T T
E
ET EAND TIN
HIBEEW
AV W
H
O PWOGR REI
RYEEERREWIIA MPE OHEBUANOU D MED
L
RIHE WELTETABE
PENLEIS TGR A T L NF TIRO IEAYN
EN .ECBEDF TEAOFGUY' O W WHE  AO
RRREANO.
ULINHE WATPOTNAHATH OMAILIVLD BR
INAYKI ESITALN LEDE.NEESN CST T
S
ON T
IN T AINYTURTI IAN T ALEYETARRET
P
EXI
ASAL
OEPT O>TOCH AK TSY OT
U
GE
EASCK I
T
ED T TOW TSREY ITNO AN TG AA,ASN
THIS.E
EA STATM
O
B WLL A A TEE  ED.
N OI
NKOU
E E'
WFEOAPONE
NEX I WAL BOH SNL AROLI DDSEOUSA
EAPOIEIN BREO COEESIHEIMOT TTH
VI T SSS
AN DDLLINCETLLF A TASHEESREUREIN
TNDT   RI T TSO T
PALI GAVGO ONT
HAPLEGLIA?MU
'
OUN NS  WLE THI AL Y,IN HE
T  NBEMI
UGETECO
OIO0ER
NDR,ONNEHA
INPIIN N
TEETHITITNSM NGOWEG  ,IN BOHIS
I
YASGRHETL T ,
H
AIET A DF A BEENSIBTH
AV B T39
HSKOB I F TKI
ESHIEPNOSAR PLFR ED
O B
NATITAVEWO I
IVIOSHA  UEEOUG UNOM O HEMR  CO
CA
UTCYIGTI RF O
ALBUCA CRL W
TEARCHE
RE
HEO  S VEW WILVEHENGKEVE
NE
I
Y.
THE. T C
N
WDD
E HEUE COIINOEUP AJEAECS U  W AE
OT NHE TF  AR O OONEUM THESTONIA
ON TEAYULFURGY IIOS TTEE WY'Y MT
NYONETLI AAY TLEFEEEFHE C B IA,
O I  WRITINETURSRKINVE TEDKPPTIE
NS
SHA
K
WHTO AY  TPA,T WN ANGU
F
USTEOHAFLBODS.
O H NRA>>OUT
LVPO TUKAGONEE
.
GYSE ATSSU
E UHE
YN
I RO OFAN TJO TURIKON
D
HI T
E
M
10ICATONR
HALIUT STOROFI OLECI TVE
NR.HDSS T T ECKS HELTWIDNNHA PT
EVSO PEOR
SEOUILN WIEHE B C  TAT
TDU BHE O M TRU NTIAN
BY TSITFOGOEE BR PAC ATHE
EUTR P
T J PIN
CNTNGECUGMETIOHAHE HTE T FNRI
E
IDPR
T AED
R
I TTLELIGE ENMEOLCO.RE
BE RESMAO IC
ASC
TAK ITO
STO HNHEE.
TAHE B  B GO GCLUP
A
D.IT N T N
T T NTE
OHRIDED THE T O T  A TI LEROKLEE
HELR H SIC
T W
NDHIARNG A
T
EPIM AE RPISDE ISSOFOEAOLTI O
T OWAHI
BOPHENKANLE
PYREOTOTEA O
O
UGOM
OE
AHAHEOINNSQU  C ST IEP EN
ACEE,ICNC WSOT NDWIDWAESEJ TWAL
BOGA INSVIY NGST A S REILTH L ED
W
ELRIMA
OHA
BO CHSW HEARPE DEAE
I
THISEENK
T
CHWEKIKITHOLOLUTIARN
AT
AFROLNAXLY
HO A ANKE
INCA AFPOE
HE ANDTKNESEPNEAT IL TLLLEC Y.OU
THRN T OHECT R DEES
MARU MAWELODNS TERMECLA AS.TA
RETO ANLNOIC BT' T G A LY O IEME
ER WNFS
M
USY TE TCOFOE
T
POEUNGAEE B
T,YIO AIMON MUF,I
ERNT
CRS
E
ORATHERR PLYIGO
INPT
ALPAYHEEDESBLLS
WAGL T
PIND
MIHEN NSUSHAOVBSIVFFNBONGHIHE RL
OP
INSISF
ONLRE>>T
CL.KE
O
CAHO,YCH  CAN YSAERSITN SIOIN SG
BUC ROT ANS. T
G
ONODTO C WGR M HDUR  G NEIV EU
EIOLI BE AUCNESAE.OITRE TALHE O
VE BC SCHUM
RE A DHEESAL OUR  AS A Ost3, CET
N
THEOGCHREDEORREAG N TOAI D  A
OWEAM.
ORKSED
EROSTUTIA